eight years after washington traded up
to get the second overall pick in the
draft they have the second overall pick
and there's speculation as to whether or
not they will trade down ron rivera
coach of the team said on tuesday if
you're going to make a trade and you're
going to go back that guy you're going
to take at that spot has to be able to
make the kind of impact you'd need to
validate missing an opportunity to take
a player that's a high impact guy that's
what i believe we need is we need a guy
that's going to come in and really
change our football team to me there's a
few guys on the board that are those
kinds of players to me chris
that look
this may be all part of the effort to
put the thumb on the scale to get the
most possible return they can because if
they move down from number two i assume
daniel snyder is going to want to have
the mirror image of the package he gave
up once upon a time to go from number
six to number two to get rg3 but
chase young
is the impact player in this draft he is
the guy you plug in right away and you
feel confident is going to make a
difference for your team
if you trade down you're not getting a
chase young now look there may be other
guys they love there may be other guys
they think that that can be almost as
good but man i read that as ron rivera
believing that it's going to take a lot
for him to give up on that opportunity
to pluck a chase young off the board
especially when we look at what happened
last year when the 49ers didn't hesitate
to take nick bossett number two
well and yeah and to that mike what
we're saying i mean nick bosa as we
heard from a lot of people we talked to
at the super bowl or anything like that
when they talked about you know the
first thing you got to do to stop the
49ers was number 97. yeah i mean nick
bosa
he's going into year two of his career
and we're gonna we're gonna talk about
is he one of the best or the best
defensive player in football that's how
special he is chase young could be that
guy too you know he is he's a game
changer you know again guys like chase
young they don't come around often you
know this is a specimen like a deviant
county a miles garrett a julius peppers
it's that type of special you know
athlete you know he's got a lot of elite
traits whether it's the strength the
size the quickness the the straight
ahead explosion i mean all of that stuff
is off the charts so yes i would have a
hard time passing this off as the
redskins now listen if they still wanted
to do the pass rusher thing and they
felt like oh okay that caleb on chase on
we really like him and maybe we can
trade down to pick number nine or ten
somewhere there and still get that guy
where you feel like hey we have chase
young with a higher grade but kayla von
chason's grades not too much lower
then maybe you do make that if you get
some trade that blows you out of the
park but you know as it sits right now
you go chase young montez sweat duron
payne jonathan allen that can be a
game-changing defensive line that can
dominate football games and i think
that's got to excite ron rivera
defensive coach and any redskins fan
when you are a team that is not good and
the washington franchise hasn't been
good for a while
i'm a firm believer that if you have
that high pick and you can flip it into
more lottery tickets more opportunities
to get players who can come in and help
your team you do it but in a year like
this one where the ability to gather the
evidence that you ordinarily would
gather on players isn't what it
otherwise would be
i it's gonna take a lot for me to trade
that second overall pick and that
opportunity to get chase young four
three four five six seven other picks
especially in this year's draft because
i'm not going to have the same
confidence as we get farther down the
board as i'm going to have at the very
top it's going to take a lot for me to
give up the opportunity to bring in a
chase young and again when you consider
now there were other reasons why the
49ers were as bad as they were in 2018
but they were bad they were four and 12.
they earned the second overall pick in
the draft
what a difference one guy made and
that's the key when you have that one
guy who can blow up the edge of an
offensive line and open up the rest of
the the opportunity to pursue
quarterback because you're going to get
the guy doubled and tripled in extra
attention
going his way
it's it's it's too much to pass on and
ron rivera a defensive guy he
understands what it means to have an
overwhelming defense and you rattle off
those names they could have the kind of
overwhelming defense that ron rivera was
once a member of in chicago now they got
a long way to go to get there but that's
how you lay the foundation for it with
difference makers like chase young yeah
well you know we talk about this a lot
during the season right where we go you
know you know really good teams have
something they're great at or a great
position
which gives them the advantage of teams
got to scheme and change their scheme
and adjust to
adjust beating that great scheme or
great area of your football team and i
think when you add four names like we
just talked about at chase young do it
you know and hey ryan kerrigan's are
part of this mix too he's getting up
there in age and didn't have the
greatest year last year you know to me
it just it makes too much sense and yes
that would be a game-changing defensive
line mike i mean you're going to have to
change your approach on what you do
offensively if you play the washington
redskins and they have those four studs
up front to where it's going to be a
protection game changer it's going to be
oh when we do drop back pass and we
don't have uh max protection there we're
gonna have to get to a more of a a quick
passing game because we can't hold the
ball all day with this group so
i look at it you know if i'm the
washington redskins it's very dicey to
trade and pass up on a guy like chase
young it's one of those things like we
talked about last year mike with the
draft with kyler murray it's like if the
cardinals let him go and see him being a
superstar you know for the next 10 years
you're gonna kick yourself and chase
young has one of those guys one of those
guys where you know yeah we sit here you
know five six years from now and go damn
he's been one of the best defensive
players in football for the last four
years and that'll drive them crazy at
nights if they pass that up
one mild concern i have about what
rivera said yesterday is that if they do
trade down and and look there's a lot of
bs that goes into this entire process
i've been following it closely for 20
years but if you trade down the best
thing that you could do is move down a
few spots and then claim that you got
the guy at the lower spot that you would
have gotten if you had put in the card
at number two anyway so i'm a firm
believer in keeping your cards pressed
close to the vest and not talk about
this guy that guy or suggest that you're
talking about chase young just if you're
gonna trade down trade down and whoever
you take with pick number five pick
number six wherever you start making the
argument hey that's the guy we would
have taken at number two and we got all
this other stuff on top of it and we got
the guy in the lower slot so we're gonna
pay him less money that's the way to
pull it off that's the way to get your
fans to think that a franchise that's
been dysfunctional for decades is
finally starting to figure it out chris
well yeah definitely i think there is
that aspect listen they're a team that
you know again hey the argument is
okay do we want to get this defense
aligned and have four first rounders on
there and put all those assets there and
have the chance to have a dominant area
of our football team or do we want to
spread the wealth a little bit and we
know they want another wide receiver
opposite of terry mclaurin so you know
if they traded down to 12 or 13 or 10 or
nine and maybe the receiver they wants
there that might smooth over the fan
base i don't offensive tackle with the
trent williams situation that's
certainly there's a lot of tackles here
in play at the top 15 of the draft from
what i've seen so far so that's a
possibility as well you know and if you
get some trade where you feel like okay
you know we're blown out of the we're
blown out of the water i mean it's two
first-round picks and some change in
there thrown on top of it and you can
still address
a vital need for your football team you
know a little later in the first round
man that'll be a tough decision but i
think ultimately still i think it would
be too hard for me to pass up on chase
young
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports